Buongiorno a tutti e benvenuti in una
nuova puntata di cucina Botanica oggi
prepareremo un piatto di tagliatelle al
ragù di funghi e noci io sono Carlotta
lui a Guglielmo non lo so
[Risate]
comunque
Benvenuta nel tuo nuovo Format di cucina
Botanica Carlotta è una persona che io
ammiro stimo e adoro particolarmente se
non lo conoscete Lei ha un canale sia su
YouTube che su Instagram che si chiama
cucina Botanica all'interno del quale
dai un sacco di ricette vegetali
alternative Senza contare che questa
ragazza è una scrittrice di successo
perché è uscita dopo il primo libro di
ricette con un secondo libro di ricette
dopo pazzesco del primo
[ __ ] no voglio dire come si dice
tutto quello che tu non sei riuscito
Esatto Bravo bravo
esattamente ed è molto difficile essere
qui vicino a lei ma comunque da bravo
signore
ragazzi se volete acquistarlo per quel
secondo libro Mi raccomando cucina
Botanica vegetale facile veloce Allora
Carlotta Calcola che un sacco di persone
in realtà sottolineano sempre scritto
sia pensa che anche su YouTube Ti prego
fate una puntata in Crossover con cucina
Botanica Cosa guadagna
sei stata bravissima un sacco di persone
volevano anche delle alternative vegane
cose che secondo me abbiamo fatto anche
noi ma senza mai dire che i risultati
posso dire
che cosa sei tu qualcosa con lui cosa
vuoi tu
Perché giustamente me l'ha viste tutte
Ecco perché ecco perché sorride e fa
tipo
che cosa facciamo oggi allora delle
Tagliatelle quali funghi e noci e le fai
tu non ti può interessare
Va bene allora non c'è uno stacchetto
proprio Ecco sì sì
[Musica]
per fare le tagliatelle al ragù di
funghi e noci se serviranno 400 g di
tagliatelle 250 g di funghi nel nostro
caso saranno Portobello un bicchiere di
passata
g di noci 50 g di pomodori secchi 3
cucchiai di salsa di soia mezza cipuda
dorata 1 spicchio d'aglio olio
extravergine d'oliva timo e rosmarino e
sale Ok Google
cosa devo fare
magari
proprio così
ma sono giganti
per ore ore dentro una salta particolare
se poi
simulare diciamo un pezzo di carne
davvero
un panino che tu chiudi e li usi per
quello
hai visto
Alessandro è andato a comprare questi
funghi ha chiamato disperato perché non
riuscivo a trovarli Hai presente tipo
non so dove stanno i funghi ma dove sei
in questo momento dal meccanico e vabbè
pomodori secchi giusto che buoni sono
buonissimi cosa fondamentale delle Noci
quindi si buttano in acqua per un 20
minuti in acqua calda tra di loro si
ammorbidiscono e quando le andiamo a
cuocere poi a mangiare non risultano
troppo croccante Ma questi qui vanno
tagliate
a
posto Ma questa è una delle ricette più
facili che io abbia Allora cosa vuoi
fare dopo
tutto questo Ok andiamo al mixer colore
Come si taglia da scuola di cucina
della cipolla quelle che non avrei
potuto seguire le immagini
schede e così fanno una scuola di cucina
bellissima hai fatto Occhio che è molto
tagliente sai della mia scuola di cucina
Come tagliarsi il cibo allora quindi
questo tagliato cosa devo fare invece
quello
di
cucina invece che ho fatto io della
strada l'aglio lo mangi crudo lo
schiacci e lo butti in padella e se ti
lamenti Pizzone cresci Fai l'uomo è
presente la mascolinità tossica il
patriarcato di quelle cose lì della
strada
Fallen completo gli occhi per L'aglio e
la cipolla
padella
fuoco
olio
così
forse un po' più
brava
certo un'altra bugia che ci potrebbe
avere i ragazzi per un bel fritto in
video
poco poco ti prego basta ora sei troppo
generosa ora esagerato con l'olio buono
prima che arrivassero a portarci loro
Noi facciamo i soffitti con quello delle
macchine No
infatti non capisco è tanto
continui a premere
gomma avevi detto che era brava Non lo
so Enrico ha scritto dei libri pensavo
sapesse di cosa stessi scrivendo come
partita questa tua passione per la
cucina
è di pomeriggio la madre della tua amica
che non sa che fare Mi pare mi fa
cucinare la torta o qualcosa così tipo
attività pericolosissime
i miei vent'anni com'è nata la tua
passione
per la cucina come aggiungo questo come
è nata la mia passione per la cucina in
realtà è molto altalenante non mi
diverte a cucinare perché perché ho
avuto un ragazzo che è più che un
ragazzo era un figlio e dietro cucina
ogni giorno io perché questo Quindi se
sapeva manco scalda una cotoletta quindi
mi è venuto l'odio è così che adesso ho
imparato a cucinare con così tanto
rancore
il
mio cavallo di battaglia e la Red Velvet
te la faccio tutta quanta liscia liscia
perfetta
anni anni anni or sono era squisita ok
No ero già pronto giù da
cucina buttata Secondo me trascina nel
baratro chiunque Che cosa sono timo e
rosmarino e se qualcuno piace il timo e
rosmarino
rosmarino Infatti non è vero infatti non
l'abbiamo proprio io a Graziana io c'ho
un'altra amica che non ama il coriandolo
potrebbe
ma
ci sono persone che li sentono come se
sapessero di sapone
che non sopportate
che quello del prosciutto crudo
Senti invece in italiano e quando un
bambino ha paura e chiama sua madre
siamo praticamente perché abbiamo fatto
questa bastarda
[Musica]
Carlotta per te è Satana capito cosa
intendo Cioè per te in questo momento se
tu andassi a cena da lei piangeresti
allora spegniamo Intanto questo e ti
faccio vedere il miracolo della cottura
dell'acqua
[Musica]
le spalle
verso l'ho inviato per la cipolla ma
servono le pinze Ma che serve a Simone
che ognuno nei programmi di cucina Ce
n'è sempre uno Forse è il Simone di
Guarda il mio occhio Simone Simone
guarda l'occhio
Mamma mia veramente come insegnanti di
sostegno
Bravo almeno un mondo Sicuramente sì 4 +
[Musica]
che botta di cura ma un mini Coppino si
può avere
un mestolo da brodo si chiama Coppino
Saliamo in aereo
inalata
di Cucchiara Chiara questa è la
Cucchiara
sgommarello
troppo freddo
aperto a
la guardia
[Musica]
Ragazzi questo il risultato finale sul
piatto Mamma mia
sudo ragazzi Ragazzi siamo arrivati alla
fine di questa puntata di cucina
Botanica tra parentesi la scelta che
abbiamo fatto oggi è proprio all'interno
del libro Carlotta È stato un piacere
immenso
No un piacere immenso Mi raccomando
ragazzi come i veri amici
andate in libreria e comprate l'ultimo
libro di Carlotta che gli dà un sacco di
dritte a prenderli pure il primo
prendere anche il terzo Quando uscirà
detto ciò vi mando un bacio grandissimo
Mi raccomando seguire Carlotta su
Instagram noi ci vediamo domenica
prossima con una nuova puntata di cucina
buttata stavolta Ok
ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]